Whitney your show is brought to you by
who the cash app that's the number one
finance app in the App Store did you
know that go it's the easiest way to
send money to your friends but the cash
app does way more than that the cash app
also comes with big cash cards with
boost which are like industry rewards
for shopping at the places you already
love them yelling and I leave nothing
purchase at your door - and even save
every time you shop at Whole Foods
Target and more cash app is also the
easiest way to try and grow your money
with their new investing feature get
rich quick I like investing tools that
force you to buy entire stairs of shock
shares of stock share SH er instantly
invest as little or as much as you want
this way you can still grow and own a
piece of any stock with just one dollar
brokerage services are provided by cash
app investing a subsidiary of square
what a subsidiary of subcision
Oh a subsidiary I can't really see that
a subsidiary of square and a member of S
IPC hmm what else are you excited I'm
also really excited to be working with
the cash app with you because it
supports one of my personal favorite
organizations The Trevor Project yeah
lots of them when you sign up when you
sign up for the cash app and use the
promo code Whitney your name not only
one name drops not only will you
instantly receive me every email so I
know buddy not only will you instantly
receive $10 but cash app will also
donate $10 to The Trevor Project an
amazing organization that provides
crisis intervention and suicide
prevention services to LGBTQ youth
across America
[Music]
that's so funny my mom used to lick her
finger up and just clean my face you
just triggered some serious PTSD at me
thank you
here we are it's 2020 2020 y'all are
listening to this it means it's 2020 I'm
better 2019 I couldn't get with it like
I could 2019 I couldn't remember it 2020
I'm gonna remember sounds more exciting
yeah
2020 I got it y'all let's remember one
number you know I mean twice remember
one number twice that's it I love
numbers aah
we're here we're here in a new year stop
banging on the table new year your new
year's resolution from me is to stop
banging on the table new year new you
you know what fine I believe we should
be able to give other people resolutions
give other people notes on their bed is
something you would believe hey I have a
resolution for you hey here's some I
don't like that you could work on I
think that's what we should do I think
we should um say what our New Year's
resolutions are okay I'm excited
my main New Year's resolution is on this
tour because you know I'm doing 25
cities this year 525 cities starting in
March Whitney Cummings calm text me if
you don't want to text me how dare you
tour ideas of what to do I am so
hardcore about this tour I'm gonna come
in the night before and I'm gonna
experience your city I'm gonna
sensuously take in your city I'm going
to be a full-on tourist but not just for
content I'm not just gonna go do stuff
around the city for selfies I really
want to enjoy America I want to absorb
this great country of ours I love that
your new year's resolution is to have
fun this year I'm gonna enjoy something
I'm gonna work less I mean obviously
because it's normally when I go to a
city I land at 5 o'clock I'm rushing
from the airport I get to the venue at
7:00 that shows at 7:30 I'm
do you know like I really want to spend
a day and write material specific to the
city so that you know my first 10
minutes is about the city I wrote down a
bunch of goals I love that don't you
think I really like that most comics
already do that but I think so I think
then yeah I think so I've always had
such a hectic schedule and then I feel
like I've been to Detroit been there 10
times have never got to actually have
fun there for the day before so in
Detroit I have my New Year's resolution
is to go to Detroit and meet mmm
does that feel okay I feel like that's a
big one if Chris D'Elia can meet Eminem
I can freakin meet Eminem okay Chris
D'Elia comedian you can mirror hanging
out with Evan that made me think this is
a very verbal goal there's also in what
we're gonna be at the Royal Oak theater
but there's a place called the Grand
Ballroom it's an abandoned Ballroom in
Detroit that's in my alley
isn't it oh gee bored we'll get right
into key we can like look for ghosts I
like anything creepy there's also a
abandoned church called the Saint Agnes
desert you're like I don't know where
there's not people if there's no more
people that I just where I'd like to go
I'm gonna go enjoy your city alone and
then I'll come see you sound good no
one's there I will hang out with the
peace like there's an abandoned
warehouse an abandoned Hospital Oh a
ghost town do a show there I feel like
I'm sure there's other tourists Houston
Houston I'm coming for you there's a
battleship Monument do you know that I'm
into like War Memorial I know you're
into war it's like a logical one
I love war memorials and there's one in
Houston I wrote it down it's called San
Jacinto battleship monument did I say
that
okay yeah the Sandy's seem to a
battleship monument I'm super into
battle shit but I'm worried because have
you ever gone to like a history site and
my influences are taken sexy photos on
top of people's graves yes we got to
watch it we got to watch the sexy
selfies on war memorials it's getting
out of hand
we need to class it up okay I was
reading that influencers are going to
Chernobyl
the Ukraine and taking sexy photos with
their titties out where 9,000 people
died at a nuclear waste site pull it
together
no they're not respect and a full
bandage wrap dress like race for your
spots
got this at BB I don't know why bandage
dress always makes me think BB for some
reason you guys love fashion no how do
you pronounce that story's a BB or babay
I've never known it's not babay I'm
pretty sure man houston Indianapolis I
looked up there's an eagle creek nature
preserve I'm gonna get nature's fuck
your good nature AF we're gonna go I
don't know it's one with some ducks what
do you do when with some ducks Dallas
are you ready what we're gonna do in
Dallas I'm ready for Dallas JFK
assassination I'm so ready I'm gonna
dress it like Jackie Kennedy the whole
tour just a pink-hatted Asia tour that
doesn't seem lifted I think they're just
gonna be like and that's where he died
no but I want to go in costume you'd be
Marilyn Marilyn I don't think she was
there that day yeah but in spirit
no that dress was see-through and too
tight for me hashtag Quebec Dora you
know that I love the Carolinas I think
that I love Caroline so or North
Carolina is one the most beautiful
places on the planet yeah home of
Nicholas Sparks movies people do we can
do this Falls Lake State Recreation and
by the way you guys text me eight one
eight two three nine seven 527 if these
are dumb ideas tell me if their badge
you guys need to DM Benton DM him and
then text us let us know there's a house
party we should go to just show up at a
house my graduation get a prom coming up
like a gender-reveal party stop it
I want to go to the lemur center and I
want to go the lemur center very excited
for Leah to make sure it's to Maine you
guys text me make sure if it's not well
going still the lemurs that's right it
needs to be accredited don't send me a
bunch of zoos you know I'll try to brake
the animals out or getting some big
fight with some asshole who's in
breeding a white tiger you know that's
my brand
Nashville trying to go to that Nashville
I'm so excited for you go national
elephant sanctuary though the one that I
want to go to it's not in Nashville it's
at home wall Hohenwald where is that oh
well Tennessee is about four hours from
Nashville about an hour and a half from
my hometown what are we gonna do the bar
bike there peddle taverns you can do in
Nashville not at home all but what you
need to do at national Oh throw the
Ryman the Ryman is for you okay
that's the Mother Church of country they
call it the car oh that's not the great
Old Opry that used to be the home of the
Grand Ole Opry
oh you see the home the grand ole rd
from 1943 to 1974 we just had a real
conversation with no jokes in it for
about 13 seconds you're welcome
that was real Atlanta I looked up this
Fernbank Museum it's a 3d theater is
that some fun
I don't Atlanta is a I love Atlanta I
think you do there's like buy you buy
let you buy nice clothes that's what you
do in Atlanta
really yeah you're richer but the Luke
the Luke the Lou
yes they love a good look in a strip
club Atlanta has the best strip clubs
really yes they have a beautiful
stripper it's like hush firm of you
strippers really not like not like
Nashville strippers Benton you're really
you're just throwing me for a loop you
want to go to strip clubs and I love
strip clubs there so those girls are so
cool they have any dreams and hopes I
love them they're named dream and hope
yeah yes we go to strip club in Atlanta
I'll be great what a good content
what great content I would love to see
you in a strip club this is kind of
blowing my mind they're fine I always
have a nice conversation with the girls
yeah yeah if you do makeup on strippers
all the time uh-huh I'm at a loss for
words kids welcome I'm just enjoying you
getting a lap dance so much from Atlanta
strippers lots of process Sweetwater
Creek State Park I'll be there while
you're at the club I'll go anywhere
called Sweetwater I'll be hiking
Sweetwater State Park while you're
getting lapped
yeah the strip come Sweetwater strip
Miami my Oh what are we gonna do in
Miami wax our pubes no bleach our
buttholes that's what we're gonna dance
right now I can start a forum career
Vegas Boston Fenway PAC so we got a
family pack yes maybe a map is vineyard
I really want there's a Martha's
Vineyard is one of the most beautiful
places on the planet that I have never
been so I kind of want to go there five
time long island we're going to Long
Island oh I want to
the medium there's a place a castle in
Long Island called the calm most steady
state park you guys are gonna have to
but also there's a long other medium
what's that mean you don't know her
Oh like the lady that yes the Long
Island medium that interacts with your
dead relative a reality show
yes she does mercy but look at her hair
whether I need to see that I love her
okay she's fun you have any dead
relatives you want to talk to no see I
do there we go I don't think I don't
want where to show I don't have to talk
to that lady I want to talk to a medium
Minneapolis there's a place in
Minneapolis called the Minnehaha Falls
Minnehaha Falls yes almost like a
comedian doing a bad joke it was a mini
ha ha I had a bit of a mini ha ha
there's a place called Lake Harriet
Harriet which is one of my favorite
names next time I get a horse I'm gonna
name her Harriet I love that so maybe
these are bad ideas but these are my new
year's resolutions I learned of Vegas
which I'm excited about I want to see a
residency show of what there's a lot of
people have residences I like to see
cher cher I've seen her before you
everywhere I haven't I don't feel like I
need to see Sheriff she flies above you
like literally thought they should
attach anything I would say I love that
obsessed with cher but I don't I'd
rather go see like those Cirque du
Soleil shows I like what I've seen that
in Vegas really yeah I like the ones
with the water yeah that's the one I
want to do different people yeah that
kind of should I like I like to see like
people maybe almost be about to die ok
Italy okay you're also going to
Cleveland I'm excited about I am going
to Cleveland I have no ideas of what to
do in Cleveland has a cemetery rock show
there's two different cemeteries that
put on free concerts in them and there's
like a dueling battle rocks like you can
go look at rocks oh like I'd actually
like that idea
no this is Museum of rock this is a
cemetery with music okay I want to be in
the middle that dancing full belting a
day like that's great over people's
graves that sounds disrespectful okay
well wait you rend it so those are my
resolutions do you have any that's my
main one let's remain resolution huh
oh my main resolution is to do more
things that scare me I hate this okay
but I know you don't like it because you
I'm not a rich white woman okay I have
real I have real fears that's a that's a
white girls go to it's like I just want
to do something every day that scares me
it's like you're basically just
bragging about how great your life is
well I have real fears well I want to
like I want to learn more about sports
that's really scary to me what do you
want to know to ask like I would like to
know I will line out like what are the
positions in a football team what are
all of them
quarterback linebacker running back
defensive end a headhunter mmm run down
her okay
cleat guy cleat guy water guy okay
kicker water boy the water boy got her
the tackle main tackle main side to side
tackles okay well up and down inside out
I think you're wrong but I do know I
actually did get a couple I wish I knew
so I could tell you how wrong a network
that's what I want I want so that's one
thing I want coach that's opposition and
a football guy flutter monger flutter
monger I know that one's wrong so you
just want to learn football I think
that'd be really helpful because then
when people bring it up I won't be
uncomfortable about it or feel like I
shouldn't be talking about it it'll be
me be well-rounded I have you just never
learned about sports because I have
never wanted to
I never sports always something to me
that I was like I can't be involved in
that it's not for me something me very
uncomfortable in my uncountable it
something I don't wanna try it yeah so
you never in high school played sports I
played uh no not in high school I played
in middle school I played baseball but I
got I had the enemy stopped because I I
was no I was ground they were like when
they was it calling the balls all ring
no Gwen the ground ball a ground ball
like rolling yeah I used to kick them up
and catch them you know how to do that
no soccer yeah so I got they just asked
me to leave I did do karate she didn't
you just course correct I try but then
also I would I would be so bored in the
outfield and stuff that I would start
like recreating movies in my head what's
her acting things out like I was
Catwoman a lot out there you and that
board faster than anyone I know and when
you're in a fascinating situation you
also look bored yeah I have ladies board
all the time it's my unapproachable
charm
so I didn't I did do karate for eighteen
years I have a black belt okay I didn't
know that Watto ruh karate wow way of
peace okay have you ever had to use your
karate uh no I've never had to use I did
I sparred I was a I did like
competitions boring for a long time okay
that was really good I was it's not
enough bragging but I was so good I got
to judge the competitions a couple years
Wow yeah about sports yeah that's really
terrifying to me also want to know like
the positions in football or do you want
to pick it to just anything I would
follow do you know who's your team uh oh
you tell me um
the Seahawks apparently are get bill
burr said the Seahawks are good so how
about them well there we go bill burr
said it I'm glad put your money on a
winner sir I don't know I'll pick
whoever the coolest mascot is that's
okay to that okay but I would like to do
that cuz I feel like that'd be less
terrifying in certain situations if I
knew more about it hanging out with a
lot of bros that are a big bro fan base
really yeah that's the kinda joke yeah
I'm the voice of the bros I'm the voice
of the people that and I also wait rooms
are terrifying to me I'd like to be more
comfortable weight room that's a that's
an area that I just I go in there and
I'm like I I think I should I should I
go what does it mean it's just
terrifying you walk in there and
everybody sort of thing know something
that I don't know they're always I don't
like about wait rooms right now
everyone's filming themselves at wait
rooms
if you're always on camera you're always
an extra in someone's Instagram video
you know I mean like there's always like
if you look down there's always cameras
leaned up against other things so people
are like filming themselves lifting
weights cuz everyone thinks they have a
channel now everyone's a star of their
own you know CrossFit show the more I
talk about this the more I'm figuring
out that maybe just confidence in areas
I'm uncomfortable in it's probably I
want to work on okay more than fears
because I don't feel couple a brand like
there are places that I feel really
comfortable yeah and then there are
places that unlike know things like a
Sephora fine yes that's your comfort
zone yeah a farm got it any of those
areas okay I'm totally good to you just
want to be able to have conversation
with football guys yeah I want to
impress you
not you but I'm impressed I am very
impressed right here what's your other
one I think that's really Oh I real
want to be able to say no more so doing
a podcast I think is giving people the
impression that I want to do everything
that involves talking you know I mean
kids like when I just did stand-up and I
just did acting or just did writing
people like oh she's so busy but now
that I'm doing a podcast I think I'm
giving off a vibe that I'm just
available for everyone's event to host
everyone's thing and I'm noticing this
thing now where people will ask you a
question but the answer is not allowed
to be no and they will pressure you into
doing something so this person asked me
to speak at their event like next month
or something and I was like I'm so sorry
I can't it's already really hard for me
to say no so there's a big deal that I
was like I'm so sorry I you know we
regretfully cannot make it thanks for
thanking me and she was like oh but
you'd be so good you'd be so good the
event would be so much better with you
and I'm like okay thank you thank you so
much still can't do it and she said oh
please there's this new thing where you
compliment someone to the point of
bullying them it's like nice bullying
which is not nice but you'd be so
brilliant like you're such a genius like
please do this I look it's like okay now
you're just manipulating me I don't like
that I don't like being manipulated and
that's what she was doing and then so I
had to say no like four times it's
already hard enough for me to say it
once and then she was a god well we
can't find anyone as good as you do you
know anyone I'm like now I have to book
your event now I work now I work for you
like it's just people have no boundaries
anymore
you have to control yourself I'm not
seeing a lot of that right now and I
think what's happening is there's a
clash between the Instagram self-help
motivational feeds that are like say no
stand up for yourself and then the
motivational feeds that are like don't
take no for an answer so all the people
that just figured out how to say no or
going up against all the people that are
being told don't take no for an answer
take no for an answer if someone says no
you know like I think we have to
delineate because I think there's this
new like well I've been told to never
take no for an answer so I'm just gonna
keep being persistent and annoying shit
out of you till I get what I want for
sure right what if this whole time they
were just planning like a surprise party
like when we really need you like we
really need you there and you're like I
can't do it like but no you have to be
there
really cool theour in this cake but you
know what that's what I felt was so
weird because they were like you'd be so
perfect for this thing we can't find
anyone to be as good as me I'm like why
did you plan an event that only I could
do like sounds like you planned a party
that I'm doing without asking me
we can't have this Whitney Cummings
event without you thank you maybe you
should have told me first
I just I don't like when people pressure
you by giving you compliments it's
confusing I that feels like a like a
business tactic if those like a thing
people out here especially do maybe
where they're just like whether they
just think that they're gonna like that
they're doing you a favor and you're
doing that it's like very slick yeah I
just my thing is like I have to say no
we I have an addiction to saying yes to
people because I don't want to
disappoint people my new thing now is if
it's definitely no like just my default
is no but I usually say give me three
days so I can think to her because what
I do is I say yes everything and then it
comes and it's like here it is it's
three hours away and we only need six
hours of your time and it doesn't pay
and it's just like I'm giving away my
time too much I'm hemorrhaging time and
energy you think there's a place to
you're at the place now or you don't
need to do that no I would like to do as
much as I can do but if I say no you
gotta hear me
yeah no means no women should know that
not just in sexual situations if I say
no I can't do your thing or no I can't
do this favor for you I don't know why
that maybe I've just given off the vibe
that I'm a pushover so people are like
just ask her again just think you come
off that bad really
no but I think there's a good point you
may because I think people are so used
to like hearing throughout their careers
in college like you know say yes
everything is everything so it's nice to
know like there's a time for no - you
have to and you also that's interesting
you say that say yes to everything
figured out later
I think there's I think there's a
difference I think people are getting it
confused in the self-help world which is
like yes say yes to adventure say yes to
a job that you're not quite ready for
you'll figure it out but don't not let
someone say no to you that's not saying
yes don't be so persistent that you're
being annoying to somebody yeah you know
like you available to reroute and take a
different path be flexible yeah me it's
a great that's a great point good I
think we do get home
up on the sake like you know that you
said taking a job take it oh that's if
you can figure out sometimes you need a
break and you should say yes to a break
yeah no I think that's a real such a
good point people like say yes say yes
that doesn't just mean to working that
means just saying yes to taking a day
off that means saying yes it's self-care
to say yes to an eight-hour sleep night
you know it is you can be the person
that's perfect for this event if you
have no time to be that person that's
correct and if I show up Haggard and
tired and annoyed and resentful that
doesn't benefit anybody and then you
leave in like conscience you know yeah
ever you are yeah and I think it's hard
now because it's like and I think
especially the podcast I've been getting
insecure because it's like there's so
many podcast and there's so many events
to do and they're like you'll be on our
social in you do and I think I've wanted
so bad for the POC has to do well then
I'm just like saying yes just so many
things and spreading myself way too thin
and you know when I spread myself too
thin I'm not the best version of myself
no anyone is though like yeah who can I
mean you can't with something like this
and you just your career in general it's
a very like you with being what you what
you do it's a lot of giving and you
can't give if you're if you're not full
yeah you know I also think that's a
really good point that's that's a big
out on things like your glass has to be
running over you don't have to have
extra to give if I and that's I say that
now I'm like I just don't have anything
to give I'm at capacity you know like
but people want to argue with me about
it think oh it's only two hours oh it's
so close to house like you know yeah
because they don't get it I think people
see someone that has or just anything
and they're like oh this is what you
want to be doing yeah have a podcast you
do stand-up oh you want this isn't this
great that we're giving this opportunity
I just I do think it's interesting I've
such a hard time asking anyone for
anything the fact that someone asked me
for something that I'll say no and then
I'll ask again I'm like damn good for
you guys I mean I guess it's the next
level and my sort of like ninja
codependents recovery like it's some
black belt shit to have to say no six
times to the same person because people
sometimes that when you say no to them
they think it's a great great
now let's negotiate that was your
opening offer for my note no is a
complete sentence that this is I thought
it's business when I want what because
they always tell you like you know just
ask the worst they can say is no yeah I
like that
no is what they say but I've said it
Livesey out of the conversation they
don't say the worst thing to say is no
and asking then if you say no they then
think you owe them a favor that's
another thing I'm nervous
so if I say no I can't do your event
whatever six months later they're like
hey circling back was wondering if you
could do this other thing it's like no I
don't know you know yeah I don't you
don't have like points I'll get you next
event no no no I didn't I don't work for
you I didn't fail you I don't owe you
four down the line because I said no to
your offer that's how people like to ask
it's hilarious oh I'm just I it's so
weird that I'm having to you know I
don't do well in email I talk about this
all the time just communicating with
people brings up a lot for me right now
I'm so annoyed about what is now people
will call you right hard enough for me
to talk on the phone I don't love
talking on the phone I prefer to email
because it's you know you get stuff done
more efficiently on the phone but now
people have ruined phone calls by
emailing while you're on the phone with
them I would say and last week at least
two phone calls I've been talking to
someone and I hear like are you what
people just email now while they're on
the phone you think I can't tell you I
can hear you you're whenever you're in a
call the someone is like uh-huh yeah
mmhmm mmhmm yeah like I know you're
doing something else I know you're
emailing what is this ruse you think
that you're pulling off and then I start
to overcompensate because I feel bad so
I just start repeating myself I'm like
yeah we should do it Friday right maybe
Friday Friday's a good day
yeah Friday is that good and then now
I'm repeating myself and then I finally
have to say something to this one guy I
was like hey are you emailing music well
yeah you're repeating yourself and imma
cuz you're emailing now I'm the asshole
I'm telling the number one way to deal
with somebody if they're emailing while
they're on the phone with you ascend
them a fucking email that's what I do
now someone's emailing I'll send them an
email and go hey fucker logout you're
like are you a mind I'm just
transcribing them I need to read it back
I just I can hear the clicking at least
be smart enough to mute the call dummy
oh you that's really getting to you
that's really crying in my gears I don't
like when people just respect my time
I don't even people it just makes me
think you think I'm stupid
oh yeah they're like oh she's a clown
she's not doing real business like this
here's my real business I'm doing
wedding
can't hear anything unless she says it I
might as well just bang away on this
keyboard I can hear it and also there's
no such thing as multitasking that has
been proven it is so obvious when
somebody is melt the jig is up
also you're wasting your own time
because you're doing two things badly
just do one thing well and you'll have a
shorter day when I was your assistant
that was the first thing you said to me
is there's no such thing as multitasking
and I was like as I was texting driving
and I was like I'm gonna look that up
it's not the brain has to switch back
and forth you know me and my neurology
obsession anyway you know me I'm a
doctor you know me I'm a doctor
comedienne I did want to talk a little
bit before our guest is here Phoebe is
here very firm yeah do you know where
have you Mary
no yes I've met her oh that's right what
was every time it's everyone I mean I'll
be like Oh Dan Mitsu this she's like Dan
Hill my Dan levy Wow
where'd you meet him I was like with you
and with you I'm very jealous that you
might have a life that I don't know
about it Peter where'd you meet her what
what's your last name how do you know
you think you're better than me well you
know I have a mental memory I have no
short-term memory whatsoever it's
alarming so I am reading comments in the
podcast thank you for everyone sending
them and thank you for everyone texting
me I am reading your texts I'm getting
back to you as soon as I can I'm getting
feedback I have to be careful with
feedback you know because I get
perfectionistic and my inner bully will
come out and I'll be a little critical
but Benton you were reading the comments
yes I love it oh really
yeah I love it because I think there's
like I think there's a lot of helpful
information in there yeah yeah I like
feedback I like constructive criticism
the most constructive criticism that we
got for the podcast a year to shiny new
people think I look like a Texas cherub
they said that they wanted less editing
because they want to be more you and I
wanted so bad to be like that's her
that's pretty much her she's like I'm
gonna give you the best version of this
I think as the show goes on
and I get tighter at this and more
comfortable and just more concise there
will be less editing so and the people
just listening you probably no idea but
in the YouTube clips there are times if
something is like too boring I feel like
or just like a tangent or this is really
when I've been editing when it's my
girls flares on when you're watching my
girls flares that's a curse you don't
have Gerdes what's a Gerdes sometimes I
have to back away from the mic cuz my
aesthetic growls and you're always like
you the amount of sounds you make with
your mouth and you're also banging on
the table so are you and that they said
that could you call me out for and they
called it out on you yeah damn it some
people think that you're a little mean
to me you know I think you don't even
agree with that I don't I don't at all I
think it's blasphemy I think you're mean
to me okay well that's a lie but I makes
you feel better I agree no I think that
um I think that it's interesting that
anyone ever say that they think that I
mean to you because I mean look we're we
definitely have biting
we definitely rib each other I mean
that's what comedy people just forgot
about Conaty remember comedy guys when
you could like make fun of people and
say things that we're necessarily true
for reaction comedy 101 but I do think
though there's such an epidemic of
bullshit fakery that when someone's just
direct with someone it comes off bitchy
oh yeah sure
yeah people are still you're my bestie
so what I'm just like hey you stuttered
people like she's a bitch also we don't
have like nice soft voices and that's
one person like our voices come off like
they just sound my whole life but they
just sound like bad you might what we
say but you look great today in people
you do sometimes come off bitchy but I
always just assume I'm being sensitive
no I've been told at my home but I don't
think you're trying to be bitchy and
this is why we've had this high talk
just my personality yeah that's what it
sound like I mean I won't tell you there
are times though I'd also think it's
it's funny like you'll just be like I'll
say something and you'll respect okay
yeah okay see that would hurt that has
hurt my feelings before
well because I'm gonna argue with you
you're in
sounds like okay but I don't think
you're trying to be mean no this is my
sound my voice is it's stuck in
perpetual puberty it's not deep it's not
hot it's just this is what it sounds
like yeah my thing is if I'm gonna be
bitchy to you you'll know yeah that's
yeah yeah yeah
because you wouldn't like I was so
impressed when you did the meeting
greets after your show you were so like
involved with the people that were
talking to you know that is a skill like
to be like that no I will not I'm at a
point in my life where I will not fake
anything and I say anything I will not
fake anything at this point in my life
and if someone comes to my show but to
me just listening to someone - making
eye contact with them I'm not like yeah
hey that is like so much weirder I feel
like I people will write me nice
messages now and I'll be like thank you
and I sound and I just I made the
mistake of saying out loud but I feel
like I sound bitchy and so now they'll
be like they'll be like oh you're doing
that thing we're used to where you say
thank you like a bitch and I'm like
that's what it's hard to say thank you
without being seeming patronizing it
ain't nobody might need a new word
because I say thank you so much that's
what I do me too I just now have to go I
really appreciate it
thank you so ver thank you out you can't
say thanks for going it's not like no
don't do that thank you I love your show
that looks like a tick we already have
too many going against us at this point
but I do think that thank you has now
hit peak sardonic you know it's like the
words genius have like a hilarious those
about lost their value
I think they should we say I appreciate
that I very much appreciate you coming
how about would you say that I
appreciate that
oh no and when someone says like great
sad ago I appreciate that
that doesn't feel genuine to me well now
I'm saying it to try to prove how
genuine it is now it's coming off shitty
we Brown good set red think about this
don't say bad thank you thank you so
much it's a heart thank you
it's hard to be grateful without someone
thinking you're an asshole it's so weird
thank you if you say things does he
thanks thanks thank you thanks I said
something the other day when it came
so shitty I was in this really big
meeting and this girl had gotten a
promotion
and I didn't want to say good for you
because I didn't want to sound
patronizing I just liked the Bravo it
sounded really weird top of the morning
it was like huh
no they know great good job like I it
sounds so I she looked at me weird
do you imagine feeling I got my dream
job Bravo that's what I said it I was
like Bravo oh great like what like it
was like a member and dirty dancing that
I carried a watermelon moment I was just
like back Bravo who says that at like
haunted me if the rest today but saying
good for you
that sounds patronizing like never
thought you would have done it that's
what good for you means shocked yeah you
did it that's like I'm proud of you
never thought you could accomplish this
I like that that's impressive I say that
sometimes that's impressive
happy for you that's a good one I didn't
know her I don't know her I wish we
could send it to people I loved her said
you know what that before you say
nothing
yeah that's awesome just cool that's
good super cool intense eye contact
nodding don't do that no yeah Wow
when summer gets a promotion what do you
say I got promoted oh I used to say it I
knew it I knew you would that's such a
good one not I need to tell people no
surprise there yeah also it takes the
whole like having to hear about it out
of it you're just like I know you want
that's so good and then one day I went
to the meeting and I knew you would say
no more that's like say don't want
that's a great way to stop someone from
telling you the story but also being
happy for them huh alright this is going
on too long
I'm not editing this part wait we do
need to talk about the fact that someone
left a comment telling us that Marilyn
Monroe's ex-husband it's buried face
down on top of her grave I started a
fire with this Marilyn Monroe rant so
Hugh Hefner's buried next to Marilyn
Monroe and now someone has written in
and said that Joe DiMaggio is married
above her so she's getting in like a the
other ex-husband Goblin throuple pond
sure that's where it is oh oh this makes
so Luke's green the pitcher oh that's
the one she looks great in a little
that's so interesting because I got a
ton of tweets today saying that name
Richard puncher and I didn't understand
what's happening who that is I thought
it was a new person like entered the
Democratic race I was like leave me out
of this I had no idea who he was
that makes so much sense so he brought
the grave plot above her even though she
married a bunch of men after him what a
desperate dead guy why are you buried
face down on her his skull you mean he's
buried like if he's laying on her
looking at her why do dead guys are so
gross so Marilyn Monroe has here her
first husband on top of her facing down
and Hugh Hefner buried next to her this
woman is just being gangbanged by these
old-ass goblins every night I'm telling
you we got to dig her up I stand by this
this is my just age that room this is my
big mission in life is to dig up Marilyn
Monroe's bones I will adopt them you
have a yard all of them back here
bury them I can set up a locker we can
have in the pod studio like we can't
even put our bones back together maybe
yeah I can do that
probably I bake necromancy Michaels okay
you see something that glue and we can
put her back together but I refuse to
allow Marilyn McCann we did a
Kickstarter going to get her bones yeah
can you produce her meaning to
Kickstarter who owns someone's bones
they're family is that true
so her but they're dead so heard she
didn't any kids
who owns Marilyn Monroe's bones we got
only wood Holly I'm for sure definitely
I did just hit the table okay I'm gonna
work on that we need to get meme it's
like you know how people insane asylum
all right so someone write in tell us
who owns Marilyn Monroe's bones I'm
interested in purchasing them we are
gonna raise money to buy some people
have fancy cars fancy jewelry not this
guy I just would like to figure out a
way to acquire Marilyn Monroe's bones
help us out we'll send you a collarbone
no you're gonna get like an earlobe you
think there's earlobes laughs I don't
know what she cremated
she's like a file cabinet though I mean
they're like yeah they're like
like a fancy morgue why aren't they in
the ground because then you can't like
move and AH them this is dirt people
want to go in but oh but I would imagine
oh it's called my producer saying it's
called a mausoleum but are they doing it
so that people don't try to dig her up
maybe maybe they've been through this
with people like me maybe I'm not the
first person to try to dig her out you
go like in watch movies that they at
that graveyard like with them I don't
know that is you're in a weird reddit
sub reddit I don't want to know anything
about but okay so more to come on women
frozen bones I'm not sure how this
became my brand my what do you call it
like my what's the thing when you have
your thing your your is your Hill to die
on yeah I'm gonna die on that's exactly
right
Phoebe Robinson's here she's an author
she has million podcast so many white
guys to job Queens movies TV I'm
shooting her TV show tomorrow actually
Phoebe Robinson she's here she's a treat
she's so funny and so smart and I'm
actually really excited about this
interview because I know her really well
but we haven't known each other that
long so I actually am NOT nervous but
also have a lot of I think really good
questions I've a lot of really good
questions we're talking about everything
that's trash and all this should i do
that's trash someone just cut us off
yell cut so I feel like we're very close
strangers yeah I think there's this
thing though when there's someone that
you've known of for a while or you watch
their work you feel really close to them
and we met in kind of a weird way like
you posted something on Instagram and I
was just like FaceTime yeah I really
forced this friendship no it was so
great and I feel like we will not see
each other for months and then we always
catch up in your Tesla for about four
hours yeah you know we're always at your
test so just being like this is the
motherfucking we get right to it though
I think that to me is the most valuable
kind of friendship where you cannot
connect with somebody for two months but
when you see each other you go hard
there yeah no formalities I mean
remember last time when we're at the the
Beverly Wilshire cuz I say there because
I'm a boozy bitch and you burn there are
all these ridiculously looking like old
white guys with like very orange skin
yes it was fucking wild I'm like why am
I staying here I should stay at a
Holiday and it's be much less creepy it
was fucking yeah but no we did sit in
the car once and talked for four hours
yeah I was like are we gonna make out
like you know the valets come up and
they're like we had to cover like 15
years of us both being in this business
yeah in like four hours oh my gosh
there's a lot I don't know about you and
we do a little quiz on this show master
your favorite animal your favorite
article of clothing and your favorite
body of water people listening the show
are telling me not to help the guest
Benton gave me the feedback loud and
clear that's reading all the comments
your favorite animal not like one that
you have or have an inner like the one
you admire the most just to give you an
idea I pick the honey badger yeah I
don't really think about animals kind of
ever so this is you really don't and
then she's wearing what for those of you
that are gonna see on YouTube she's
wearing a cheetah shirt that I actually
have to you homage oh my oh we do
whatever you want
time's up on people telling you how to
say we can be super it it really is
bringing me a lot of joy I mean I want
to look cute for you and I wouldn't
maybe one of the nicer things anyone's
ever done for me
you know I was wore shoes that I own I
don't look at anyone else's style of my
own
shout out to rail great button-down I
love right are they sponsoring then I
don't know because I only their rails
shirts all she wears
me and Justin Beaver both wear rails I
swear to god you'll send me photos and
be like where's this shirt is it the dry
cleaner or not if I can't find one of my
rails I have a Pan Am well you have four
more so just pick I have I buy
duplicates that I'm so afraid of my lows
on high if something fits and works i
buy two or three of them and then if I
can't find it I panic and I scream
where's my rails by the way doesn't work
for me anyway so it's just like this
weird friendship I'm like where am I
sure
I don't live there I'm sorry you don't
think of animals that much but one that
you admire will see it it kind of takes
your breath away
oh you know when I was in Africa that
sounded really annoying you know when I
was on a safari with some white people
as you do on his walk
yeah I was in Zambia and we saw just
baby elephants just crossing the road
and it was the cutest little thing to be
following their mom around so I thought
that was really cute so I say elephant
they got this struggling can you give me
what I need three adjectives to describe
an elephant the one like Oh
regal mm-hmm independent mm-hmm
kind mm-hmm okay that's perfect great
your favorite article of clothing
obviously that shirt this is so hard
it's gonna hard bent I've never done
this with you what is your favorite
articles yeah I would pick a jean jacket
I think oh yeah my animals a starfish oh
that's a really good one
okay that's great the resilient there
you need oh oh they're creepy as shit
unique yeah okay no I'm with you okay
they glom on to thank me I was doing
that tuna comment ten minutes ago I
literally I'm calling onto you I was I
can't take long I was a glam my glam on
it oh you know what I would say okay so
there is this vintage shop at the
Brooklyn Flea Market and their Instagram
handle is mad good vintage oh good and
they have these really super cool like
one-of-a-kind leather and denim jackets
and like like really cool artwork on the
back and so I have two pieces from me
that I love one is like a Lenny Kravitz
like black leather jacket with fringe on
the sleeves great it's very extra
and not where to Walgreens and the other
piece is of this like oversize denim
jacket that has you to sort of
spray-painted on the back like wouldn't
join the 80s or in Joshua Tree yeah and
I you know I wear to the concerts as
good luck and finalists all the jacket
he thought it was great so give me three
adjectives to describe these jackets um
cool um comfortable badass yeah yeah and
then your favorite body of water
I picked the new River in West Virginia
a lot of people pick oceans pools I'm
not allowed to tell you yeah okay cuz I
don't know any names of bodies of water
I'm like I don't know where we if you
were gonna do like a watery vacation
what would you like a river Louise
you're in the bathtub
I'm not a big water person I'm not a big
beach person yeah but I only take baths
not about are so disgusting I use
antibacterial soap with a loofah I mean
you're just sitting as your skin flakes
are just chilling we've talked about
skin flaking off tried to tell me the
reason that we people mimic each other
you know when you spend all the time
with something you kind of started
mimicking that yes he said it's because
he read in an article that weren't
hailing each other's dead skin cells to
be fair though whitney takes the fastest
bass I've ever seen I mean she's in and
out I'm like do you even take a bath did
you relax and she does I'm super
hardcore but I know Tim levy takes a
shower after he takes a bath which I
thought was wild I've heard people do a
lot of people do that yeah I think I'm
in the minority that I just sit down in
the shower you don't yeah if I'm tired
I've seen Girl Interrupted
like an orphan in the rain I love Baz I
only take baths I have a little thing
that I put on my stuff on my phone and
my Luke lucky I'm disgusting I also
stink I also do smell myself so kind of
like that's chowder body water it
doesn't have to be in either oh so just
like like to look at even I think links
will be like a glass of water what if
you picked up water in a sink yeah I
wash my face yeah I like a hot tub not
to be late a Bachelorette I do like a
hot tub huh
you know it's just nice and cozy I don't
know how to swim but I know how to prune
yeah and I think it's cute yeah yeah so
what are some adjectives describe a hot
tub cozy the UM unsanitary like for sure
there's never clean never no I just have
a myth in my head that when water's hot
it kills germs yeah but that's just
something I made up to justify my
disgusting behavior yeah it's just not
not scientists yeah okay so unsanitary
relaxing and hot huh is that lame no not
at all that's exactly it's okay this is
a test that Sigmund Freud developed to
interview people to find out about their
subconscious this and they say
apparently that your favorite animal is
the way you view yourself I view myself
as a she highly moisturizing at all
times
fuck you Sigmund independent kind regal
oh yeah okay yeah all right all right
I'll allow it
you also just you also said struggling
is accurate I don't think you're
struggling but I do think you work so
much that I would imagine there are
times when your have a full plate yes
you know yes balancing I fill up at the
buffet
it's nuts you mean we'll talk about that
minute you think we got a lot yeah yeah
a lot unpack there we'll put a pin in
that your favorite article of clothing
is the way other people view you your
black leather jacket with fringe or the
u2 jacket vintage jacket cool
comfortable and badass is that how
people see I really with it 100% okay
Benton yeah for sure okay sure
cool interesting about this is normally
the way you perceive yourself and the
way other people perceive you are
slightly different yeah and usually
there's some work to do in there but
you're really clear because like mine
was you're a honey badger
you know scrappy ruff has to fight
everybody always at war that's why so
myself and then other people saw me as
hoodie comfortable classic yeah you are
a classic really yeah oh that's a weird
that's a weird thing to say about no
self it's I mean old no it means like
like you could fit in with any time like
you know some people are like you could
truly only me right now literally ten
years ago this would be fucking garbage
this is your window
yeah it's closing shit just open and
it's about to close this is the elevator
of people is it's ephemeral yes that's
so enjoy your journey throughout time oh
that's yeah yeah like the movie kailia
Paul do you be throughout time
white women refuse to be race we really
have dominated every era of time correct
and will not back down so that's
probably true and your favorite body of
water is the way you view sex cozy cute
hot and unsanitary no what are we doing
that's why we shower yeah that's the
whole point of why we shower
look Benton's doing his thing where this
is how he itches his face yeah we you
wear makeup you do like that okay I said
I knew it but you want women always have
my back and I don't let's just point
that out but you have to just give
someone a heads up like I haven't you
know know I can oh you know you just do
it and you go back to your talking I
know but I thought that's great yeah I
would I'd be like Whitney I'm about to
itch
please allow it no he'll do it it like
very high-stress situation like about to
go to talk to her like okay see me and
I'm just like I can't stop hurting
yourself you do it so aggressively
you're self harming and it makes me
uncomfortable I'm codependent I like to
pivot hard on this show I love this book
so much I actually hadn't read this when
I met you and I'm glad I didn't because
I think I would have been a little bit
scared of you why I don't know no just
because I think I was just so I'm just I
was just I'm impressed and I'm glad that
I met you before I was like oh fuck I
would have been like a real like dork
fan if I had read the I feel like we met
each other in a good order something I
love so much that you did and
everything's trashed but it's okay
is that you not only explained
everything that's trash and why everyone
should read it
so this world just goes a little more
smoothly but you mentioned some of the
things that you do that are trash yeah
and I don't think a lot of people
understand how important that it I mean
but yours are also like kind of a dreg
yeah but I think it's really important
that people understand that if you
cannot see the things that you do that
might be a little precarious it's a lack
of intelligence anyone who thinks that
they're flawless and everything they do
it just comes off silly if you think
you're perfect right and I'm gonna tell
step program and the fourth step is
called an inventory where you take your
inventory and you made all your secrets
and all the bad things that you've done
and it's a great way to release shame
and it's like calling yourself out
that's basically what it was and when I
was reading I was like oh my god that's
so cool she's kind of like doing that
without even knowing it
and I thought it'd be funny to go
through a couple things that I do that
are trash okay let's here with you and
you can tell me okay great
when I fly on a plane I take my chewed
gum and I put it in between pages of
magazines oh that's fine I'd really well
like put it on like your sitting area
then I was like what the fuck yeah but
that's a psychopath yeah yeah I put it
like in the magazine Benton seemed to
say that was really rude yeah what if I
want to read the in-flight brochure
that's guy mom Kellogg what do you go to
buy an aquarium table so you just like
pick up Allure magazine you're like
flipping through no it's like the it's
like the sky magnet it's just what oh
it's the airplanes man
aziz whatever magazines they're like the
one with the rules in it
you must stop but i just what else am I
gonna do with my gun if i'm swallow it
oh I always swallow gum great I do it
out like two days it's fine I do too
yeah why I stop doing that
I think it just recently stopped small
and gun that's so weird
because I think I got embarrassed one
time actually I know this is what
happens someone shame because I swallow
gums I'm having sounds like did you
swallow your gum and I was like no like
you no one calls you out on something
don't call me out on that now ya feel
stupid I think I got embarrassed
yeah just swallow it or what I do if my
gum is I if I have a water bottle I'll
just stick it in the cap yeah that's a
good one and then like my water kind of
tastes minty Li yeah it does yeah I
because I never know to do because if
you put it in the barf bag that's even
shittier cuz what if someone needs to
barf and then they can't open it you
know or your chewed gum is in there then
they're gonna have to double barf well
shouldn't I be checking those I'm like
changing them out each flight I mean I
mean have you flown anywhere really I do
a full wipe down you know like Naomi
Campbell like that whole thing I do that
I do
I pulled the Wet Ones out and I wipe
down the see the console to everything
the seat belt mm-hmm it's grating fly
with anything on your face every once in
a while do a mask uh-huh but then
overall um
because I wear zit patches out of my
apartment yeah I just thought it's it
patch on my boyfriend is always saying
you know you want to leave with that I
was like yeah they said yeah yeah it's
called self-care yeah so sometimes it
started uh playing with some zip patches
on yeah I'm trying to better myself
I do zit cream very aggressively on
planes I do machines you know that new
face machine I use I do that on planes I
give a shit you know good news about the
crazier you act on planes so less people
will talk to you it's great it's that
because I have this I give off this vibe
that like and like crazy people really
want to like tell me about like their
divorce yeah and so now I realize like
the noise canceling headphones the
crazy thing I'll put on those wet masks
on him and I'll do all kinds of crazy
shit and it people like think twice
great about digging into having like a
secret family with me I don't there's
something about my vibe where crazy
people think we're friends it's such a
bummer another thing I do okay when I'm
traveling this is such a dumb lie and I
hate when people do it to me if I don't
respond to someone I'm like sorry I've
been traveling today I've just I haven't
been able to great but I'm sitting still
for five hours it doesn't matter you bet
you're traveling so traveling is a I
have a total pass to not have responded
to everything absolutely even though I'm
sitting the airport for three hours just
doing yeah absolutely aveline your pre
traveling but traveling and sitting
there on your phone that's all it's the
only time that I'm only looking at my
phone and doing absolutely nothing else
but it's like you're on a plane or
you're like in the you know at your gate
you just want to eat your fucking Tim
Hortons or whatever but that meal holds
yeah okay yeah they look good excuse
because I will sometimes lie and say I
didn't get a text message I'm like I
came through the green yeah I lie why do
I do that that's crazy
I just mean I always go oh I thought I
wrote back yeah that's a good one my bad
thought I wrote back isn't it right yeah
you just own it yeah the fucking adult
yeah why not did it slipped your mind
you're busy yeah okay I don't know why
it's so hard to just let people know
that oh yeah since Phoebe has a numerous
hit podcast do you want to throw a break
since you've been doing this for so long
you're such a pro yeah what would I say
hey guys cash app period period then you
guys are listening to go for you I'm
Whitney Cummings and I'll be right back
Buffy affair Buffy betting you know that
nothing's more important to me the
betting because I can't sleep and I
spent most of my waking my bad nothing's
more important to me than Buffy so great
the show
it's earth-friendly it's cruelty free
where is mine
they sent me one and you stole it put it
no they see my own and also I already
owned one cuz I loved it so much ok umm
yours I upstairs I put it on your bed
well I can't find it I think someone is
running sleeping with it right now
Buffy's products are made using only
sustainable and recycled material
awesome which makes them a soft on the
planet as they are on your bed ooh that
is so romantic sounding our latest
product is called the breeze it's a
comforter made entirely of 100%
eucalyptus fiber to regulate temperature
and keep your cool and comfortable all
day long it's great which I also love
cuz you're not using down feathers so
it's cruelty free regulates temperature
no more night sweats oh god I hate it I
always sweat in the mellah night I'm
sweating right which makes me think that
I don't freaking have this comforter
that you were supposed to put in my bed
the breeze is mostly made of eucalyptus
fabric and can you read some of this
please yeah it's cruelty free no down
here sleeping has always been an issue
for me and Buffy makes everything better
that's a quote from someone not me
because I can sleep through anything but
I love the comforter for $20 off your
Buffy comforter visit Buffy CO and enter
code Whitney that's $20 off your Buffy
comforter visit Buffy CO CO and enter
code Whitney Skillshare we 2020 this is
the year 120 it's a new year here to
explore new skills deep in existing
passions get lost in your creativity
with skill shares online classes I'm
gonna try to do is keep existing past I
have lots of existing passions that I
would like to deepen and this is what
Skillshare a it's an online skill share
is my main passion it's an online
learning community where millions come
together to take the next step in their
creative journey with thousands of
inspiring classes for creative and
curious people on topics including
illustration design photography I want
to do that video freelancing and mo
skill share is an online learning
community that offers membership with
what meaning with so much more to
explore we
this is like a whole thing it's classes
to make you like better at things it's
school for $10 a month it's basically
like school you can do whenever you want
it's affordable ten dollars a month I
want to do uh I want to do the
photography 101 do you want to do I want
to do the freelancing one so that you
can actually take good video for once I
said free I didn't say the video I said
freelance it Lansing what okay what do
you mean take good video it wasn't the
topic you just threw that in there out
of nowhere
no shares of proud sponsor of good for
you explore your creativity at
Skillshare calm slash good for you and
get two free whoa to free months of
premium membership wow that's a that's a
hot deal really uh two whole months of
unlimited access to thousand thousands
of classes Jesus get started to join
today by heading to Skillshare calm
slash good for y'all tonight was that
allowed swallow you also so loud it was
like I was cold coating myself so
everyone is doing a little bit of ASMR
on the show I think that's yours that's
my favorite one and I used to do it to
Jessica all the time in the studio and
record two dope queens I just played
that's my favorite and she would hate it
so much
III think the problem is I hate how much
I like it I think it's more that you
know what I mean that one is oddly
sexual right I didn't feel that what
else would that sound like they're gonna
old Manning soup oh you guys are
terrorizing me it's enough if you ever
heard two people go like that do you
watch them no I know yeah I know they
exist
I appreciate the culture it's a big
thing so yeah it's a huge thing I like
the UM the scratching I just like it
when the people whispering yeah I just
like people whispering because one girl
I was watching and I found myself
falling in love with her and I don't
know why what Springs the worst thing
you can do for your vocal cords right
now I don't I think that's true I
actually think that's true I think
whatever I do in my stand-up is the
worst thing for now
it's not taunting her something I want
to call myself out on it is that I
sometimes try to boss people around by
pretending to be helpful oh I do that
too I'm bossy it's fine but it's yeah I
bet you as someone who's now in charge
of people do you find yourself worrying
about other people's feelings and how do
you tell what to do something with grace
and elegance yes I'm reading this book I
love self up so I'm Rena's book called
radical candor mmm-hmm yeah it's a great
book is all about like being a boss the
workplace I'm like you know just getting
your mind right making sure you treat
your employees well and like realizing
you know like the first thing I realized
once I started becoming a boss was that
like you actually work for your employee
just as much as they work for you you
know it's like you want to make sure
they feel appreciate it and you're
nurturing their dreams right and you
know I think a lot of times when people
don't tell Benson yeah I think a lot of
times of people get into our positions
they sort of lie to themselves that like
people are dying to work for you but
it's like you're paying them that's why
they're here that's correct
like a man is a great assistant she's
here hi I'm Angela volunteer oh you
don't just want to be here it's not just
your dream to watch her dreams can live
audio but like you know I asked her to
do like order my sweet green salads yeah
doesn't want to do that right she
doesn't want to order my guacamole
greens I'm paying her that's right and
so I think you have to understand that
like you're not this treat to be around
24/7 yes you know any me and so you just
realize you were also a person with your
own flaws and your own ups and downs I
think it allows you to sort of put
yourself in the pan I used to be an
assistant so I think you can put
yourself in a position of your assistant
or whoever your employee is what their
position is and understand what they're
going through in order to work for you
I'm glad you're saying this because as
I'm thinking about it as sometimes when
I've asked for something like that and
have felt weird like god I feel like I'm
bossing someone around I'm her and then
I'll go like well I had to do this or
when some
you know when I'm to direct with someone
or not communicative enough with someone
or not clear enough with someone I'm
like well no one was clear with me I had
to figure it out and I Adid shit and
then I'm like that doesn't mean I should
perpetuate the cycle
I came up under the idea is to be better
than the bosses I've had yes cuz
sometimes I'll rationalize my own
behavior by being like what everyone's
fucking shitty to me and I had to take a
bunch of abuse but that's not yeah yeah
of course correct yeah of course
and it's also like um like anything the
more you know it's actually I find
because I remember this journalist was
like following me around for something
it was like you're so nice to everybody
and I was just I thought it was so sort
of weird comment what's going on out
there number one but number two actually
being nice to people whatever that means
is kind of selfish because like well
everyone's better at their job yeah if
they feel respected it's also I don't
like go to work every day I go I'm gonna
respect everyone cuz that's completely
against my instinct
but it's also like you get better work
out of everyone yeah you mean to people
you're actually just hurting yourself I
know and I think people don't understand
like what I think a lot of people want
to be a boss I think I get to tell
everyone what to do it's not what a boss
says yeah you're like it's truly worried
about overhead it's truly being like
checking in with each employee making
sure they're feeling like you I do feel
like you're kind of like a parent in
some way yeah and like these are like
your kids and you're really just like I
want to make sure everyone's happy and
good and feeling good all the time and
it's really it's it's a little more
exhausting I thought I was gonna be but
I do enjoy it I mean I think that a lot
of people think if you know being a boss
means I have to boss everybody around
and tell everyone what to do all the
time if you get off on that I can't help
you yeah you know yeah it's your journey
and but I think the best bosses hire the
best people and then leave them alone
and let them do the job
so if you're telling someone what to do
consoling all the time you've made a
hiring mistake yes it's it's a mismatch
yeah and it's also so many people have
so many different skills and talents
yeah if you just get the fuck out of the
way that's right and let them flourish
and shine they'll surprise you and
themselves and make it they'll learn
skills about themselves that's right
they can really do all these amazing
things so it's like don't hinder someone
so you can be like my name
is on the check no one cares I also
think it's really important that you I
felt being the boss meant I have to know
all the answers all the time you don't
it's great it's just actually the
opposite you go what do you think yeah
what do you think should happen and then
you could hear everyone else's idea and
then your job is ultimately you have to
make the decision yeah and be decisive
but I realize like sometimes the boss is
the person in the room talking the least
yes took me so long to understand that
really yeah yes okay yes was the hope on
this cuz I was so insecure that I think
that but the first time I had somebody
like okay this is the thing that I made
so I have to know everything and I don't
have answers for everybody and it's I
thought my job was to do everyone's job
and they're all like what are we doing
here so when you have Whitney mm-hmm
where you kind of like that on the show
where you're just kind of like well it's
also like a lot of pressure when it's
like your show is named after you you're
laying I gotta be involved you know I
was also so young and I was so scared
and I was so dysmorphic about what a
healthy working looked like because I
didn't have mentors I didn't have women
to look up to I never had sort of seen
powerful women running things and my
main priority back then was making sure
everyone liked me and what I now know is
if you want something like you get them
out at a reasonable time not you know
too mean so just be direct with them I
think most adult people don't want to
you to beat around the bush in terms of
feedback they'd rather you just tell
them what to do so then they go home
sooner you know I think I was so worried
about hurting people's feelings for so
long those no I mean I like this but I
feel like you know and I like it yeah I
do like it which is like totally
responsible communication and totally
infantilizing people that just kind of
want to be told the truth you know I was
assuming everyone was the sensitive as I
was or something you know and I think I
also again I thought that I had to make
every decision I didn't understand like
oh I can delegate and I can say well
what do you think yeah and I can empower
other people to make their I thought I
was making their lives easier by doing
their jobs and I wasn't they were kind
of just like confused and like what am I
doing here
yeah but it is it is tough being a dream
killer if you have to be like oh no you
can't do this or yeah I don't love this
idea or I've working on my talk show and
there's something where I was like oh I
actually don't like any of these
questions and I said
tip of the show run I didn't send it to
the writers when I was like I don't like
these questions let's like do some more
and it felt kind of mean to be like oh
I'm not loving these questions but it's
also like we're only going to get to the
good stuff you know no one's nailing it
all the time like it's we're at a joke
you have to revise it a bunch so it's
it's fine it's every book in hand
everyone's fine yeah everyone can is an
adult you know but I also think I put a
lot of pressure on myself because in the
beginning of any business any endeavor
that you're doing any website you're
starting you have to really make the
target clear to be honest so if you are
saying no to people about things
creatively in the beginning you have to
tell them why you're saying no exact you
know so that they can get better at
their job I think that's the biggest
mistake I see a lot of you know people
making and then if I experienced I was
just like no and then you're like well I
don't know I don't even know what I'm
pitching on I don't even know what the
target is you know you say and Benton
I've probably been overly loquacious in
this area where I'm like no and here's
why
yeah well I think you were a great boss
and I feel like I was sometimes like
overly and I never wanna feel like I'm
micromanaging but to say like these
questions don't work for me because I
just want to get to the root of it you
know so then they go great that won't
ever happen again
yeah most people just want to be good at
their jobs most people want to feel
pride you know and I think for me I'm
always trying to figure out how can I
have someone in this environment feel
pride when they leave everyday you know
yeah that's great that's I mean thinking
that way it's like I already know you're
a good boss well they want to go like I
finished that Joker that was my idea you
know whatever you know and and I think
it's just the way you say it I think
it's just sort of like you can say no in
a way that's graceful I've started and
I'm always always about sharing like
tools that that help people of just like
you know I've been thinking about it and
this doesn't work for me and here's why
mmm
saying I've been thinking about it just
helps people know that it's you've been
thoughtful about something and then
you're not just like willy-nilly like in
the moment like nagging something yeah
you know I love that yeah I've been
thinking about you know given that some
thought mmm
that's how manipulative no this sounds
good yeah that's solid yeah but just and
here's why I think everyone can handle
no as long as you tell them why yeah you
know okay we were talking about the
trash shit I was doing yes where do we
land on self-deprecating you know Hannah
Gatsby really shook this the shoe
turn my world upside down yeah yeah you
know I I think it it's situational yeah
and it's about intent because I do think
that like sometimes people's self
deprecating is an expected of you
sometimes you self deprecating on the
other person if like yeah i remise
myself single for cuz i mean they're in
a relationship I'm like horrific Li
single and you know sometimes when
people aren't couples they can like feel
bad for you and you're like I'm fine I
may go bad so you like let me make jokes
about so we all feel like I'm fine yeah
yeah I have to take care of your
feelings and yes my feelings that I'm
not even having yeah but then there's
also like self deprecating I think a lot
of times when we can do this because if
you're accomplished or you're killing it
or whatever you want to sort of minimize
yes so that's bad but then the times you
just want to make fun of yourself
because it's like you're a fucking idiot
yeah I'm gonna make fun of yourself so I
think it's okay it's comedy but you're
like crutch that's when it becomes like
well what how do you really feel about
yourself that's right yeah that's right
and if it's not truthful or if it's just
to get attention or it just feels like
an old habit and I think when people
when you self-deprecating you also have
to just think about the position the
other person's in when suppose like I'll
because I'm an idiot now the person's
like do I have to talk you out of this
like now I am it just puts other people
and if stop doing it if anything because
the other person yeah has to then sit
there like when I watch someone that I
respect her admirer self-deprecating I'm
just kind of like do I have to laugh
like I suppose a lot like it just puts
me in a weird situation you know but I
definitely still have that habit and I
think there's a fine line between having
a healthy amount of self-criticism and
edifying yourself and self-help and
self-deprecating yes and I think it's
constantly trying to figure out that
line because I found for me when I was
like I need to get my shit together I've
got a thing a lot of things I want to
fix but it was turning into like well
because I'm crazy and I'm it's like no
not well hold on yeah I there were some
you know I was poorly parented in some
areas I need to reparent myself none of
this is my fault
I don't need that kind of like negative
self-talk and I think especially like on
social media because I mean everyone has
followings now if some so even if it's a
thousand people 500
people when you talk about yourself a
certain way it number one teaches people
how to talk to you hmm
and it also people go like oh well she's
an idiot then right yeah yeah yeah I
looked up to that person Ron Funches one
time I loved him he's so funny I loved
him so much so funny the nicest person
um him and Dave should just Duke it out
a girl role Oh I mean there's a lot of
days I will get a good starter going to
fund that event no he he it's really
helpful to me when some and it's so
interesting I don't think you'll even
remember this it's so helpful when
someone that you know well enough to
respect them and know they're not trying
to hurt you or sabotage you or don't
have any like major like glaring like
malignant narcissism issues but not well
enough to where they're not gonna you
know play into one of your patterns or
something remember when I was shooting
my last special I called you for advice
I don't those look I know she's gonna
tell me the truth yeah
and you talked about this in your book
you mentioned something about one of
your agents or something giving you
feedback and you're like why pay him of
course he's gonna tell me that right
right right
I think it's so important that you have
your stable of people that you ask and
you know you're gonna get a straight
answer and then you can believe them the
good and the bad when they say something
yeah
so for me it's also like in this
validation search we're all on it's like
okay this is somebody who told it to me
straight when it wasn't great news and
so now I can receive a compliment from
them when they actually get yeah
but I asked you something about I was
just like is this a trash show yeah and
I think I said it was a good joke and I
think I needed to hear that because I
was so full of fear of getting something
wrong the cancel culture it's very it's
not nuanced it's like it's just as bad
as things before right now it's like
well no one's perfect everyone's gonna
say something wrong you're these that we
are saying now
are going to be wrong in 10 years that's
right so it is interview yeah we'll get
us both basically sent off to our home
in the Hamptons to live in our basement
something we're saying but it's true
where Pete especially doing comedy I've
only been doing it 11 and a half years
you're what a good amount of time oh
thanks okay and it's like you could just
feel that sometimes are ready
mm-hmm to be like you said this wrong
you can sense that urge and it's sort of
just like I understand why you're like
well I don't want this recorded yeah
yeah and then five years on my cringing
cuz I said you know that's exactly what
I was going through and I think for me I
don't want I'm happy to cut a joke I'm
happy like if it hurts someone's feeling
I'm just like okay it's not worth it to
me it's like I you know but at the same
time we can't capitulate to you know one
person I remember when my last special
came out there was a picture of a robot
on the billboard and someone was
implying that I was making fun of people
with prosthetic arms and I was like I'm
out it's and for those reasons I'm out
it's ridiculous like what's the fucker
weed it's no no it's a robot I mean what
what you ready to talk about boobs
Benson yeah always
this company is freaking awesome
it's called third love it uses
measurements and millions of women to
design bras with all-day comfort and
support I love this because they have
half sizes they have half cups they have
a a through I I've never I don't think
I've ever met someone who's an i but I
I thought you btq ia I including half
cups and brand bands ban 3348 all made
with signature memory foam cups no slip
straps in a smooth band scratch free
band I'm actually really excited about
this so that I'm actually stuttering
find your fit in sixty Seconds over 15
million women have taken their online
fit finder quiz to find their perfect
fit
what do you think my fit is what do you
think about 30 60 okay wow this that's
hurtful
how is that her I don't have d boobs oh
I'm sorry that I thought you purchased
the best of the best the bigger doesn't
mean better you should know that at my
frame that's when I would purchase if
you need extra assistant third loves
team of expert stylists are available to
answer any of your questions there's a
perfect that promise every customer has
60 days to wear it wash it put it to the
test and if you don't love it return it
at their level watch and donate it ah to
a woman in need that's so cool comfort
and quality hands down the most
comfortable bra you will ever own straps
won't slip third love knows there's a
perfect bra for everyone they also fit
finding your size is fun which i think
is really interesting because I could
imagine going into a store and someone
being like human and measuring in oh you
know be fun if you read the green part
okay third love knows there's a perfect
bra for everyone everyone so right now
they are offering your listeners 15% off
their first order go 2/3 love.com slash
Whitney now to find your perfect fitting
bra and get 50% off your first purchase
that's third love.com slash Whitney for
50% off today
thank you Bob Barker it's so clear the
person has no yeah watch her read yeah I
am determined to not be that I'm like on
this page you said and you were talking
about self-doubt and it was I mean there
was a point where you were talking about
being in a photo shoot and not wanting
to you know ruffle feathers and I
thought oh yeah well they didn't have
any clothes that fit me yeah I want to
circle back to that what I was told to
I'm gonna tell you what I was told to
take after the break I'm gonna start
being one of those people like you know
in the local news really like oh he's
LED and your child's drinking water
you'll find out after the great the pill
I was told to take by stylist I was told
by a stylist when I first moved to LA to
take adderall and another one to say Jo
just do one line of cocaine 3 days a
week that's no one's talking about how
that's chill nor a person I'm poor like
what where this is before postmates like
where do I get cocaine like what are you
even talking about but Noah's time at
the stylist
contribution chill out of this you seen
the very relationship with your Scottie
is great and she will literally cuz I'm
like at 10:12 and she's very much will
tell designers like this is ridiculous
you don't have her size like she will
just like custom this stylists are such
a big part we're gonna help make this
change as well cuz they like a lot of
people like I like we get samples like
that's what they used to do they would
say like these are all size zeros if you
don't fit them you don't get them yeah
you know wild yes I just bring my own
clothes to shoots which is crazy crazy
yeah but it's also kind do you feel like
since you've started things are changing
I mean no I think here's what I do like
I I did oh my god what shoot was this I
can't remember
I shouldn't say what it was first of my
boo boo ass magazine and they didn't
have enough looks and so I was just like
you know what this has been great I'm
gonna leave so I left I was like if we
don't have enough looks I'm out I was
like I'm not gonna do this and so that's
my new thing right like if people want
to say you're difficult or whatever
let them say but it's like if I tell you
I'm a size 10 and a 12 and you bring me
a four lol why am I here I'll just pay
for the liable offense I mean that's
like like I think people forget it this
is a business
yeah and that is a real job if you go
ask your car to get fixed or say I need
to change four tires and they only
change to like why is that not okay but
in this business it's like well yeah
this is your job well I didn't pick this
job for you yeah I I was very clear and
upfront with what was needed that is
wild and it's just also you know because
I think about I'm like I'm not even
plus-sized you know any mean and I'm
just like no woman should ever feel like
I don't you're excited you're like oh
I'm gonna do this magazine shoot I'll
make it glam like you like you're pumped
up you're like I'm gonna have these cool
pictures again and I feel like a goddess
or whatever and then they just like
blatantly disrespect women in a way that
like I don't think I've ever heard a guy
be like I did this shoot and nothing
said you know to me but literally
every woman I know has like multiple
experience we're like well I couldn't
fit anything but we had to do it you
know it's not and if you and this really
drives me nuts is that when it if you
can't you're like I'm not gonna fit in
out there like um it's all they sense
yeah and it's like no no there's none of
this was my fault yeah literally none of
this is my fault
I used to internalize that shit all the
time you did something lazy you were
sloppy
you're participating in this Size Zero
you're trying to like get in good with
the designers whatever bullshit politics
that goes on with that stuff like yeah I
think the same way a lot of people
aren't talking about the agents being in
voluma setting all these meetings with
these pervy producers like I am sorry
I'm so sorry I mean why is no one
talking about like I think that the same
thing with a lot of this body stuff is
like the stylists are really at the
front lines of all that stuff yeah and
it's like I don't need to wear the
clothes of designers who wouldn't want
me in their clothes in the first place
yeah I don't need to wear it in a
magazine that's right like come on I I'm
glad this is coming up and I like to
sort of tread carefully in this area and
my my big brand tagline is we're gonna
cut this I say after every life we're
cutting this we're cutting this but I do
feel like there's lots of panels right
now oh my god I mean I am an it didn't I
just say yes to doing like three panels
next year I love panels you guys look we
love panels but what runs are
translating the actual change yeah I
think is where's the check at the end
someone's buying tickets for all this
you're getting money on streams and at
least send the panelists of video or
something they can post on social like
where's the exchange in this yeah give
me some dip tea candles candles yes
the thing is now you've been oppressed
and this business has been unfair to you
so now you come for free and talk about
it for no money so we can look
progressive like this feels like a weird
weird angle its it is weird and I'm
starting to be a little more selective
now yeah no I'm just like it's not worth
my time I'm like if I'm gonna do you
have to pay for my glam yes yes you do
it because it's like you're going
obviously you're going to take pictures
and if I look like trash I will get
roasted online so you have to pay for
glam you've got to pay for
transportation at his self-care
I hate when they're like just punch in
your code and uber no get a sedan that's
it that's it it's very simple
I wanted sedan this is I think that
they're uh such a and every woman in
every business I think can relate to
this sometimes self-care or just basic
asking for what you need
my thing is I will be better if you
provide this for me yeah
I will be better if I'm not rushing
around texting and driving not knowing
where I'm going I don't know where to
park I'm gonna be flustered I'm gonna be
sweating like just help me show up for
you yeah I'm helping you now just give
me this little thing to make sure that
I'm at my best again it's also the thing
that I want to say is like will you
agree to do a panel that's like I don't
know you have to prepare for it you're
doing the actual thing it's like those
are like five hours that's right
that you could be working on your
stand-up or doing an audition or
something that you leave indicating to a
panel yes that's right you're paying for
that time that is time that is the one
thing we cannot get back yeah so for me
I just found it odd that there were all
these like women's empowerment women in
business women are bosses panels but
they're not paying them I'm like I think
because you picked me for this it must
mean I'm empowered which means I'm gonna
have to ask you to do this and this and
this you picked the wrong women panel
about empowered women you're gonna have
some notes we got here in the first
place I mean I think cuz I'm kind of
over social media like I'm not posting
as much it's feeling very it's a lot
it's too much it's too much it's like
full addiction it's a tremendous
pressure I just don't want to do it like
I'm sick of updating people about my
life I've been like if I don't post
about my boyfriend like did you guys
break up and it's like oh we're living
yes yes yes yes oh I have you I have
you necked in with you therefore
something horrible must have happened
the way people it's tricky though I
think though because when people fill in
the blanks it usually says more about
them so when someone does do something
like that I'm kind of like oh no that's
where your head went yeah I'm just like
he doesn't want to be on camera
I don't either but that's what it is all
these people right now that people are
like where did that caught that bill
burr so great Sebastian so great they
were just getting good for like 20 years
they worth spending all of their time
making swipe ups and yeah they were just
getting good and doing exactly that you
know I feel like so much I'm like I got
into this to be a stand-up comedian but
all I do is market myself I'm not a
marketing major I don't want to I'm not
good at press I'm not particularly good
at marketing but I feel like this is all
I'm doing 24/7 you know but I think the
very very skilled comics so you could
take the power back though that's the
thing is you can actually just be like
I'm not gonna I don't follow
say it again a different way unclear I'm
waiting with them you could just be like
I'm just not gonna post on Instagram
like I will sometimes go a couple weeks
without post on Instagram and it's great
I'm like fantastic it feels so good to
just like go through my life I fart I
shit I like do and it's and you don't
post it I'd uh are you insane
that's a squatty potty endorsement deal
hashtag ad hottie squatty partner but it
feels so good to just be like I'm just
in my body and I'm just trying to like I
don't know it's so weird because we grew
up before all of this
so yes you know we're the last
generation that like remembers life
without social media being yep the like
performative living being living we used
to need a stoplight and just look around
I know you just be bored yeah we usually
like get bored yeah just like sit in a
doctor's office and just like I remember
I used to like count tiles on ceiling
yeah yeah you would just sit there now
anytime you have a break you're just
looking at there our brain never has any
time off I know and it's really show I
mean it's showing up I think I've seen a
lot of ways you know
attention span is getting it's terrible
abysmal yeah
that's so wild I think for me as someone
I tend to definitely outsource my
self-esteem sometime to that shit and I
really I want to be open about it cuz I
think this is gonna be the next big
epidemic I think we're gonna look back
on social media you know in 20 years the
same way we look back at smoking now or
gonna be like can you believe people
just have their phones out all the time
like a dinner it's crazy I know we used
to just I mean have you ever looked at
your screen time yes and sometimes
you're like you're up 23% and also what
the fuck did I do last week yeah it's
bad not good but I also follow 15
different YouTube fan accounts on
Instagram so I like to be up to speed
do you think there's any famous fan
that's bigger than you for you two of
you two and I promise I wouldn't bring
up you two
no let's talk you brought it up I yeah
to be fair I so I think Ava Duvernay has
seen them for tea time what and I am on
number I've seen them 19 so I'm trying
to catch her I'm trying desperately to
catch her this is a wild piece it's like
two black women are like riding hard for
that Irish PD we are we I I think I did
DM her and be like I gotta catch up to
you you like started laughing like I was
just it was in it I think was like in a
magazine or whatever and they just asked
her like how many times she's seen you -
so like 30 or 40 or something wild I
know but I love it it's like my favorite
thing I don't think I've done anything
42 times I know or 19 yeah it's great I
might fly all over the world to see them
it's like not a game so I don't I don't
really go to concerts they make me super
anxious I love going to concerts but
it's like I'm not you know what depends
on the fan base yeah that is the future
has a wonderful fan bases it's just like
divorced dads yeah but it's really like
a lot of like teenagers will be there
it's like they just like run the gamut
I do remember one time a friend of mine
got married and when they came out you
know after the ceremony when they come
out for the first time people de que my
god that's like so we were all bought
that song it just makes you cry yeah
there's some science there's got to be
some science to it because everyone
started bawling I'm like is this like a
like a Pavlovian thing because we've
heard it during better times back when
it came out with more innocent days or
is it just that beautiful the song it's
just one of those like iconic you you
really get a Mike gives me chills down
my spine when I hear it yeah but they're
the best we should get we're gonna go to
a concert again can you have sex too you
too or no no that's the rule he was my
boyfriend cuz we know but so this was
early on in our courtship when he my
boyfriend lived in Portland I went to go
visit him cuz we were a long distance
for like the first year and I always
have a youtube t-shirt with me I always
travel with one just like we're like
around the apartment or whatever we're
just like hanging out watching movies
and we just like started having sex was
just like whatever fine and then we were
doing like he like flipped me over do
you like doggy style and on the back of
my shirt is of you to he was like okay
you gotta take that off before I enter
you cuz this I don't want to look at
therefore fucking moody ass face that's
good no red flies there and he was like
finally perfect on though do not move so
we no no on the playlist and no pictures
of you two in the bedroom alright yeah
which I'm like that's fine I feel like
that's gonna make him stay that's that
is a strong boundary yeah I respect bebe
for that and I call him BB ya BB is cute
that's a couple more things I'm gonna
get you out of here because I want
respect
time no we I'm having fun that's morning
a couple of things if you want I love
you so much any money advice I really
like to talk about money on this podcast
aving it spending it what's worth it
what's not women and their money
everyone and their money okay so I have
a lot of feels and I wrote about this in
the book but I didn't write about this
in particular so I think a lot of times
people get very confused by people like
us in the public eye because like you
know we get paid decently or whatever
but then it's like okay so they might to
pay agent uh-huh lawyer publicist blah
blah blah so it's like anytime we get
paid it's like you may be seeing 40% I
think that's kind of part of the reason
they pay us so much so we have to give
so much away yeah and so I think it's
sort of like I think anyone in their
life no matter how much you make you
have to you get your money up to realize
okay I'm paying taxes I'm paying rent
I'm paying my bills this is what I
actually I'm gonna get huge so then I
can figure out what how I'm gonna live
because I think everyone lives what is
it what's the difference gross is before
tax and that is after tax so I yeah so I
think people live based on gross not net
that's so true yeah and then also I
think my biggest thing cuz I sixty
thousand dollars of financial debt
something that was like student loans
and then credit cards and just like I
had so much shame about it I want to
talk about it and I think nothing you
just stops on the street and be like I'm
fuckin broke like you don't need to do
that but I think having conversations
whether it was like a friend or like
you're like people don't even tell like
they're the people they're having sex
with like in a relationship financially
what they're dealing yeah you know what
I mean and so I think not like taking
emotion out of money and realizing it's
not an emotional thing yeah and like
it's just to help you live your life
better yes
it really makes you not spend it
emotionally either you know yeah cuz I
used to be like I don't feel good so I'm
gonna go to Zara mhm and it's like
I love me some Zaher Zaher but it's also
like as I say stars are beans like wait
what's the race of charge I was like
this could not go well but you know I do
think that like feeling bad about money
is going to affect the way that you
spend it huge because they have like it
your hate fucking it yes there's such a
taboo about money I think especially now
the Instagram with everybody's like
showing their best life runner you've it
in Russia there's a jet you can rent by
the hour just to take pictures in to
pretend you're on a private plane that
makes me so sad heartbreaking and that's
how you devastate you know private plane
to to where to yoga to the people so was
that were you going it's just a shuttle
off its lemon what are we doing what are
we doing so I also think take
responsibility for your bright don't
brag it's it's not helpful to your
friends either what bad can you look
like you sometimes I what if I saw
someone on a plane like oh jet they do a
renting but I be like what a loser yeah
like you're the person who unfollow you
but you're such a loser the private
plane pictures are becoming an epidemic
if you're in a real private plane love
that follow you all day yeah but if
you're just on a fake private plane get
away from me I don't know if I'm with
you private planes are so bad for the
environment okay I made that straddle
the if I were ever to be on one I don't
think I would post about it cuz that's
right I think so too and then my last
thing about money I just will say that
like sometimes it sucks like sometimes
it is you have to make a lot of
sacrifices yes and you know I think
about like when I first started out
doing scene I was like horrific we broke
probably like the first year and you
know so it's being like okay I'm not
gonna you know I'm not gonna go on
vacations I'm not gonna take taxis I'm
gonna pack my lunch and so like I feel
like because of social media and stuff
people only see the good side of like
how everyone's career came to be and
they don't realize all the sacrifice she
had to pass and sometimes it's like
that's what it takes it's like I didn't
go on vacation for five years yeah
because I couldn't afford it and not
okay and so I think I want people to
realize sometimes you have to like eat
shit yes and no one's posting that no
that's like taking a selfie with their
bag lunch yeah you know so I think it's
also like we just have to remember I
look you're not seeing a lot of that
reward I think it's also unfair to
remember like like you just said if
you're on a private plane you wouldn't
post it but if I'm following you that is
your life like I can't be mad at you
because that is the way that you live
you know I know but Benton you're
weirdly too evolved in this area we
disagree I'm a size double zero I don't
gonna have to do panel last thing I'm
asking about our gifts cuz I love giving
gifts and I love I think a lot of people
are bad at giving gifts and then want to
get better at it myself included what is
a good gift for Phoebe Robinson what's
it get a gift for me or is there
something you like to gift or is there I
always like to give candles that's like
one way everything gifts that's like my
default gift such a good gift because I
always feel like candles are just like a
little too expensive to buy on your own
yeah but when someone gives it to you
it's like the greatest to me that's my
number one received gift yeah it's just
like soothing and especially you come
home from a stressful day you're like
I'm just gonna like this candle and calm
she the fuck down yeah so that's great a
handwritten note is also very nice my
hair my handwriting is kind of like
serial killers like and not to bring him
up but Bono did write me he has written
me quite a few notes minutes just I have
them framed and it's so known if you're
not Bono I don't need a hey give me a
handwritten note I just like what I did
I'm special oh thanks I had a custom
made card done for you remember you
actually did and that was really that
was pointed the card meant a lot to me
for like a good gift giver deceitful
you're very good at giving gifts he once
made me a doll a stitch-up doll that
looked like me I think was a voodoo doll
you in horse I had it made yeah he had a
doll made of
was not my favorite gift but when she
took me on tour I got her this like
custom piece of art from his place that
she follow she followed them and I was
like hey do you like this place that she
went I mean I guess and I was it okay
well I did get your gifts from there and
she's like oh I do I do you like it
that's so funny
well I just I think giving people gifts
it's expensive so I like to for people
to be careful with how they spend their
money but I think that a handwritten
note is good yeah you're not spending a
lot of money yeah or like um I'd like to
spoil people that's my thing oh that's
nice that's what money I mean that's it
feels good I think to give gifts as long
as you're not keeping score yes I like
giving framed photos that's a big one
for me that I like to do gifts that I
like are gifts gifts books that I like
make good gifts
I love getting books that I wouldn't
have known about what was the one you
said fearlessly and uh radical can
radical can I forget the name of them
well poster see you later the gift of
fear is a book I really like to give
people which I have right there getting
the love you want is a good book my
Harville Hendrix to anyone in a
relationship it's wait his name is
Harville Hendrix it is that's something
that's a choice I mean the title even
getting the level that the name is
what's bothering you about this book
well it's just like Harville hannover is
what my doctor walked into anything I
gotta operate I'm doctor Harville
Hendrix I'm like I'm just gonna walk it
off yeah I mean Mercury's in retrograde
I'm a Libra
frankly I'm sure it's a great book I'm
sorry Harville no he's me he is big on a
Mago therapy about how we're attracted
to people who have the negative
qualities of our primary caretakers so
when I see people repeating patterns and
bad relationships I'll just slip them
that bug that's nice give a self-help
book without going like you need this
right because that's it that is what it
is it is yeah really annoying and have
lots of flaws and I can't take it
anymore begging you to read this but
what I'll do is if I'm gonna give books
I'll give like books the same book to
everyone one year so that it's not like
I'm just giving you this one and they're
cater to the flaws I think you okay it's
like everyone's getting Michelle Obama's
that's right dude that's right that's
such
a good gift yeah they're like one year
this is so embarrassing the first year I
ever did it it was a book by Osho which
he later ended up being the wild wild
country sex cult leader
remember the Rajneesh did that
documentary the Raj and I had to like
email all my friends really sorry about
that
documentary just came out and this man
ran a sex cult and put beavers in a
blender to poison the water supply of a
bunch of people well I didn't watch to
dub the book though read page four there
are some there's some helpful stuff
she's just getting out Michael Jackson
CD I know there's a lot of I just had to
get rid of a lot of books in my library
there was one that was like The Iceman
Cometh Kevin Spacey was on the cover and
I was like oh shit yeah I know that's
teen yeah I really loved American Beauty
and I can't watch it such a bummer a lot
of a lot of books and movies had to get
cancelled he's in a bug's life i watch
it with my niece he's one of the
characters in a bug's life and he's so
fuck which girl I forget I'm gonna look
it up but he's so good in a bug's life
and my niece and I'm just like yes Queen
let's watch this again I guess this
appointment that's because I gonna say
we can't watch this movie because Kevin
Spacey like so now you say nothing
yeah just like heartwarming tale yeah
I'm sure
yeah I'm just gonna sit in the corner
and shiver but you enjoy the movie it's
a great I've never seen it whoa any red
flags in friends making new friends as
an adult I believe people should heed
red flags our time is valuable and I
think people some people are vultures
and I've taken me a long time to figure
out that if someone comes on too strong
too fast yeah that might be a red flag
yeah if someone like puts you on social
to fast
oh yeah that's a little I'm always a
little weirded out about that I'm always
like if you always like whenever you
first meet someone you're always like
let's get a pic just don't get to pick
the first I don't know yeah cuz it feels
a little bit like look I'm hanging out
with this person as opposed to just like
you enjoy I'm hanging I'm actually
hanging out with or now can you take a
picture of me yeah just met I don't know
you're good I don't work for you if
someone tries to make you their personal
photographer - yeah and that'll
establish the dynamic it's a red flag if
you can't be silent around someone so
with Benton I never felt like I had to
perform around Tim like we could just
like sit in silence I love saving in
science is so great so hard though if
you're around someone you find yourself
being like what do you mean look what
you're doing but like that means
something about them is making you feel
like you're not enough or you need to
entertain them or perform yeah I'm kind
of at a point where I can't be friends
with people where I feel like I have to
entertain them or take care of them in
any way yeah I think it's great so
that's something we had so that's a big
one I think a lot of people don't know
that if you hang out with someone for a
couple hours and feel exhausted oh my
god there might be something else got
the idea of friendships is not to
deplete you it's to energize you it took
me a long time to learn that a man's
sister you're like I'm exhausted no no
you're such a gas to hang around I'll oh
I wish we leave lived in the same city
but I don't know I feel like we I think
the same way happened how long distance
relationships I think are really healthy
I think when you start out in different
cities you're forced to actually get to
know each other yeah and not overdose on
each other and let all your neuro
chemicals of like passion and lust and
sex can you know can sometimes you're
just like I don't even like you yeah I
just we're so close we just you know
proximity is kind of why we're dating I
think that it really weeds out yeah that
relationships of convenience but I think
it's good for friendships - yeah like
when you're in town we really work hard
to see each other it's cute yeah it's
really cute I love it and I do feel like
it's taken me a long time with people
that are in the same business as me to
not feel like I have to talk about work
when I'm around them you know that's a
that's a struggle I think sometimes yeah
I go home I guess we have to talk about
all the work thing sometimes you can
just be fucking silly yeah and not talk
about work all the time I feel so much
pressure right now as like women in
business to be like let's give each
other the life hacks I'm gonna conquer
this business like sometimes the best
thing you can do is to just like have
authentic silly time and recharge you
don't always have to be like hustling
and plotting and planning and I just
always feel like I want to like compare
notes and share what I've learned you
know yeah
so sometimes I mean a new friend and I'm
like okay this is a seminar we're
forming a company you don't always have
to form a company with everyone to me so
what are we collaborating on you know so
it's like always finding that balance I
really struggle with that and then I'm
kind of like every work friends are we
real friends I think I put did that to
myself because I felt like I only had
you know yeah yeah just I do you feel
like you're more relaxed now
yeah person now that we're on camera I
feel really relaxed with you millions of
people are listening
I feel super okay I'm seeing you
tomorrow this is her she doesn't post as
much as I do because it has self-respect
and self-esteem no but I will post her
how my feet how about that so she does
not have to post yourself I love you
baby
don't write elephants I also have
another book too
oh wait you keep oh yeah there's that
too so many books more books than Tina
Fey more books than Tina Fey more books
and Whitney works for me you'd be fired
but I mean that's a choice fired no I'm
nothing else to say I don't gonna do
another book I want her to you don't
want to do it do another fucking book I
read the foreword do it I can't I'm not
here though you're so young you got time
you seem very different for when that
book came out I would like to ban I
would like to have a repo writing the
book changed me writing the book all of
the things so funny when people come up
to me and they're like oh my god I'm
going through this of codependence and I
have this thing and I'm like oh well I'm
through it like it's so right that's the
name of your next book oh stop talking
to me like I beat it no but I think that
this is writing out and which is why as
already said when you wrote this stuff
like you're sort of mini fourth step in
here when you write all of this stuff
about yourself it's so healing yeah and
the book healed so many parts of me and
I'm like
I'm not as broken as I used to be am I
even interesting anymore so everyone
should write about yourself that's part
of why 12-step programs work so well cuz
you're writing about all this stuff and
healing all these invisible wounds but
yeah I kind of am like I need to go make
a bunch of more mistakes yeah we would
like to know about the good part of your
life I think people have to remember
facts whoa that kind of blew my mind and
I almost blew past it I never think that
that is true I never think that that
something going well is entertaining for
people if you do it in a way that's not
braggy not sure you find those moments
of still like I'm revealing my flaws not
just like I'm fucking nailing it
syndication money like you know anything
oh my god right yeah but doing that if
as many good things as go on you're
still actively going through your steps
and you're actively going through all
these things you're always growing your
books have some of the best cover art I
trekked it's amazing like you see him on
a shell from a mile Mandy Tucker took
both pictures she's fantastic
Delina Medan does my makeup and first
first wig first book first wig is oh
wait both wigs are navaja right I think
anyway okay they update their Instagram
yes okay good there you go the second
cover looks so much like my cousin it
looks just like her wait you have a
black cousin all my cousins are black on
my mom's side my aunt's makes you marry
two black guys though okay I was like
there was the the connector here yeah
you know my pieces are Filipino brought
to you by the how how but I did see
you'll be like should I Wow this is
gonna get I she said I mean a man to put
her phone down weird I was like are we
calling the public
download the cash out for free on the
App Store Google pay play Google Play
market $10 for you $10 for the travel
project oh my gosh guys that's that's
what we do here
don't write elephants you know where to
find us
I'm not saying all this shit you know
we're you know what to do
you're adults that's great you're adult
yeah that's a great sign on your shit
out I'm not doing this for you if you
have you know if you can't find it
that's I can't help you
[Music]